[Music]
on this friday night
the chief of the tacoma to schwett
mcfirst nation calls out
the catholic church there has never been
an apology
her message to canadians and why the
community doesn't want the former
residential school
torn down in manitoba pressure to
preserve the final resting place
of indigenous children not even in death
are they at peace
calls for a city to right or wrong the
race to administer the second dose
the last thing we want now is that a
variant arises that is resistant to
fully vaccinated individuals
plus no paid sick leave and no other
options the problem essential workers
can't afford
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
bara nasser good evening and thank you
for joining us
the chief of the tacoma loops to
shredmake first nation is calling for a
national day of prayer
chief kasmir is asking all canadians to
take time this
weekend to mourn the 215 children
believed to be in unmarked graves at a
former residential school
in kamloops bc now is a time that we do
some important grieving
and healing work in our own communities
for many indigenous people across the
country it has retriggered
trauma they live with every day
something the prime minister
acknowledges
the hurts and the wrongs
the intergenerational trauma
the layers of
barriers and
harms that continue to this day not as
part of our past but as part of our
present
require an awful lot of work by all of
us
in our top story tonight paul johnson
looks at the work that is
already underway and so much that still
needs to be done
please know that indigenous peoples
across canada
is being heard are now dealing with
trauma
and deep wounds acknowledging that
they're coming from a place of trauma
and grief
to kamloops to schweppe mcchief roseanne
kasmir
gave the first update to the media since
news broke
of the horrifying apparent find last
week among the things she wanted to
clarify
they are not calling this a mass grave
this is
not a mass grave but rather
unmarked burial sites that are
to our knowledge also undocumented
as far as technical details about what
equipment was used
who conducted the search with ground
penetrating radar and how that data was
processed and analyzed
those facts will be released to the
public but not now
these are preliminary findings and that
we expect to have a final report
near the end of this month kasmir also
called on the branch of the catholic
church that ran the school the order of
the oblates of mary immaculate
to release records pertaining to the
school she also called
for a public apology from the church in
the end what we do want
we do want an apology a public apology
not just for us but for the world who
also shared in those suffrages with the
announcement that the rcmp has opened a
case file on the discovery kashmir said
the mounties will need to follow
their lead on the investigation pointing
out historically
the rcmp were involved in forcing
indigenous children
into residential schools as the memorial
grows in front of the former school
building kasmir said their intention is
not to tear it down
as other first nations have done but to
leave it standing
as a stark memorial to canada's history
of residential schools
paul johnson global news vancouver
on monday prime minister justin trudeau
said dealing with canada's awful legacy
of residential schools
was his top priority and he promised
what he called
concrete action now at the end of the
week
trudeau is again promising concrete
action though as david aiken explains
the government's next steps
are not yet clear yes there is
much more action to come there is much
more work
to be done but specifics for now are
missing though some indigenous groups
say
one step would be to hand over documents
that indigenous communities say
are vital to helping locate burial sites
and
information about children who never
return home some of those documents are
held by ottawa
some by institutions like the catholic
church which in some cases
has refused requests for documents as a
catholic
i am deeply disappointed by the position
that the catholic church has taken now
and over the past many years trudeau
hinted that should requested documents
not be forthcoming
the government may compel their
production we have tools
that we can use because truth
is at the heart of understanding our
past and
preventing further damage to the future
and in kamloops or anywhere else in the
country
rcmp and other investigators will be
expected to go
slow let's remember again that this
is uh potentially a crime scene
um but also will may well be considered
sacred grounds
and people will have views on these that
we will need to respect meanwhile there
are calls for external bodies like the
united nations
to investigate canada for crimes against
humanity
in connection to residential schools
that's fine trudeau said but
only if the wishes of indigenous
communities have top priority
it's not up to international bodies to
choose to come in
although they would be welcome it is
about
indigenous communities having the tools
that they need to move forward
and so next steps from ottawa will have
to wait as the prime minister and his
officials
insist that it will be indigenous
leaders not ottawa
that decides what next to do and when to
do it farah
david aiken in ottawa thank you in
brandon manitoba there are calls for the
city to buy back land where the remains
of residential school children are
believed to be buried
it was sold years ago and turned into a
campground
survivors and family members call it the
ultimate
indignity global's marnie blunt reports
a quiet and chilling scene stuffed
animals
children's shoes and tobacco lay on what
was once the foundation of the brandon
residential school
reflecting on a tragic legacy and
remembering the young lives lost
david moore was seven years old
when he died he survived three months
at brandon residential school um my
great-aunt lydia
uh his older sister was 13
she survived one year after school they
are among the approximately 54 children
buried beneath the nearby turtle
crossing campground
for years family members along with the
sioux valley dakota first nation
have been calling for the city of
brandon to buy back and protect the land
the ultimate in dignity is not even in
death and they at peace
not even in death that they at rest
because they have
vacationing campers on top of where
they're buried
kayla matheson's grandmother is a
survivor of the brandon residential
school
who volunteered to go to be with her
older sister
how do you process mass graves of small
children and
how do you grieve for something
that's so large
and i can't i can't say that it was only
because my grandma was indigenous
that my heart broke the city says the
land was originally sold with the
stipulation that the burial site be
preserved
but as the land changed ownership that
has been lost
the mayor says buying back the land
isn't off the table
this needs to be first nations led we've
had great
collaboration with sioux valley and i'm
very confident that quite soon we'll
have the solution for most you know
dignified and appropriate
reconciliation for these children the
chief of the sioux valley dakota first
nation says through research
archives and survivor accounts they
believe there are a total of 104
possible graves
at three different cemeteries in the
area however only 78 of those
are actually on record marnie blount
global news
turning to the pandemic now in canada's
vaccine rollout
federal health officials now say 65
percent of eligible canadians have
received
at least one dose in the territories
enough doses of moderna have been
delivered to fully vaccinate
85 percent of people 18 and up and over
the next week they're expecting to get
enough pfizer biotech vaccine for all
youth
12 and up prime minister justin trudeau
says
pfizer has committed to delivering more
than 2 million doses to canada
each week until the end of august and
because of the vaccine's popularity
he says pfizer will be adding 3 million
more doses in september
now there's still no concrete schedule
from moderna beyond june 13th
and the company has sent just one third
of its planned spring shipments to date
canada's top public health officer is
stressing the importance of getting
two shots dr theresa tam says the delta
variant
first found in india has now been
detected essentially across canada
and as abigail beamon reports more
testing needs to be done
and faster
looking for variants can take a long
time but this robot can complete genomic
sequencing in just 24 hours
and its lab found toronto's first case
of the delta variants our capacity is
you know as easily hundreds if not
thousands a day these senior
investigators estimate they're
sequencing about
20 percent of positive covid cases in
ontario and they could be doing more
there's not enough varying testing uh in
in
across canada there's not even enough in
ontario to be honest
important as the number of delta cases
grows and as we learn
more about it there's now increasing
evidence to show that it is more
transmissible
data from the uk shows fully vaccinated
people are much more protected than
those with just one dose and that's the
majority of canadians
the last thing we want now is that a
variant arises
that is resistant to fully vaccinated
uh individuals obviously the sooner we
can
get second doses done uh the better it's
going to be
provinces are shortening the gap between
shots as supply ramps up
quebec down to eight weeks closer to
over three million
quebecers will probably change their
dates
but community pharmacies in that
province say there's been too much
delivery uncertainty they're not sure
they'll get enough to meet that
shortened time
frame while in ontario pharmacy phones
will be ringing
as that province announced the early
booking age drops to 70 on
monday but we are examining the the
potential for expanding that to
all age groups the health minister says
staying ahead of the variant will be key
for a return to normal life in the
country's most
locked down province abigail beeman
global news
ottawa
in new brunswick the crown has dropped a
charge against a doctor who failed to
self-isolate after a trip to quebec and
then later tested positive for the virus
dr jean-robert ingola was accused of
violating coven-19 measures
and charged last august under the
province's emergency measures act
he briefly traveled to quebec to pick up
his daughter and returned home but kept
seeing patients
the province suspended ingola without
pay after his name was leaked online
as patient zero the ordeal led to racist
threats for the physician who is of
congolese descent
premier blaine higgs has been given one
week to issue an apology
or face legal recourse facebook updates
its relationship status with a former
u.s
president coming up how long donald
trump is banned from the site and why
plus a detained journalist televised
confession
contested
there will be no return to facebook or
instagram for former u.s president
donald trump
at least not anytime soon the social
media giant is
upholding its suspension of trump's
accounts extending it for the next
two years the announcement comes as
facebook lays out new rules
for all politicians aimed at restricting
hate speech and misinformation
as jackson prescott reports critics say
neither move
goes far enough the january sixth
insurrection was the final straw for
facebook
it banned president donald trump from
the platform for inciting violence
a suspension the company will extend
until at least 2023
they shouldn't be allowed to get away
with this censoring and silencing trump
said in a statement
the social media giant has long operated
with two sets of rules
everyday people are barred from posting
hate speech and threats of violence
while politicians could post almost
anything facebook felt
that was in the public interest i
believe that the former president should
be responsible for his words
and that the people who broke the law
should be responsible for their actions
rising political violence has led to
growing scrutiny and the threat of
government regulations
and so facebook has put politicians
everywhere on notice
warning as with trump we will remove
content if the risk of harm
outweighs the public interest this is a
global problem we've seen
particularly in countries like india
where
politicians inciting violence have been
allowed to keep their posts
up the move doesn't go far enough for
tech reform advocates
while conservative groups claim a
violation of free speech
it's about corporations making key
decisions about the freedom of
expression
and preventing harm from spreading
online for the world's largest social
media platform
not acting was no longer an option even
if that means
incurring the wrath of its most powerful
users
jackson prosco global news washington
the family of detained bella russian
journalist roman provoseevich says he
was coerced into making a confession on
state television last night
he was arrested last month when his
flight to lithuania was forced to divert
and land in belarus
he's accused of organizing
anti-government protests and
disrupting public order
in the highly produced tv segment the 26
year old broke down and praised
president alexander lukashenko
admitting he was trying to topple him
human rights groups and the country's
opposition say it's clear the journalist
was tortured
his father says they broke him and his
son would never
say such things
will canada's hot housing market cool
down still ahead what younger buyers are
hoping for
post pandemic
you're watching global national
[Music]
in our series priced out we have focused
on housing affordability
for young canadians those under the age
of 35 who say
they can't buy into the red hot real
estate market home prices have surged to
new highs across the country amid the
pandemic
but what happens after it's all over is
there hope for millennials to get their
dream home then
our senior business correspondent ann
gaviola explains
housing is very tied up with my sense of
security
and my mother was a renter her entire
life
and i've seen sort of the insecurity
that comes from that
31 year old anita min has been hoping to
buy a home with her partner for years
but with her budget of up to 800 000
she's not seeing much they can afford
the average home price in the greater
vancouver area is more than 1.1 million
dollars
i think the question housing
affordability plays a lot
into whether or not to have kids
because housing is an expense children
are at expense child care is an expense
all of these things are related
historically low mortgage rates a race
for space and a rush to get into the
market ahead of tougher borrowing rules
fueled a surge in home prices during the
pandemic
and it's not limited to major urban
centers prices are up about 30 percent
across canada
bringing bidding wars and buying
frenzies to cottage country and smaller
cities like hamilton halifax and moncton
when we think about prices going forward
the fact that there's still low supply
out there would argue for
elevated prices as well economists say
housing supply wasn't keeping up with
demand or keeping pace with our growing
population and an influx of newcomers in
the three years
prior to the pandemic and when borders
reopened that's bound to increase demand
and prices
even more this week prime minister
justin trudeau pledged more money to
address canada's affordability crisis
he said owning a home is too far out of
reach for people in canada's biggest
cities
especially young people and families
policy experts suggest
an urgent need to figure out and align
immigration policies with affordability
measures
we need to make sure that the way it
gets solved is
is both economically and environmentally
sustainable
ann gaviola global news toronto
who's protecting essential workers next
how canada has failed some of the most
critical people
in the pandemic
time and time again throughout this
pandemic we've been told
stay home to stay safe but for canadians
who don't have access to adequate sick
pay
the decision to stay home without pay
may not be a viable
option christa hessie on the calls for
more to be done
to keep workplaces safe this simple
memorial is a stark reminder of the toll
that kovat 19 has taken on essential
workers
since then like yo i've been asking that
question
what happened amanda young kaluchi's
brother godfrey young
was a long time employee at canada post
in mid-january he worked in night shift
at the gateway facility in mississauga
ontario
the 62 year old developed a cough then
tested positive for covet 19.
six days later he died the facility was
experiencing a covet outbreak
and there were close to 280 positive
cases
canada post declined global news's
request for an interview
and said in a statement that it has
implemented rigorous safety measures to
keep employees safe
and has closely followed the advice of
public health officials
including distancing and screening of
employees it says it also offers
paid sick leave essential worker like
him
have to dictate that type of risk every
day the question is
who's there to protect them workplaces
like food processing
warehousing and manufacturing continue
to be a key driver of transmission
in ontario alone 68 workers have died
after contracting covet at work
according to the province's workplace
safety and insurance board
more than 25 500 workers have been
infected at work
and advocates believe the numbers are
under-reported
dr andrew buzzari leads a team of
researchers who have been studying
so-called hot spots in toronto and peel
what has been driving the heat and the
unequal exposure of covet they found
that 63
of people who live in hot spots are
racialized and are more likely to be
essential workers
in manufacturing utilities trades and
transport
they're also more likely to be
low-income earners often working
precarious jobs without access to
adequate paid sick leave
if people are going to stand up and say
you know these people are heroes
which i fully endorse we have to make
sure that we're doing
the work and we're providing the
policies and supports
that is more than rhetoric every single
case
every single death these are not just
numbers christa hessie global news
toronto and tomorrow night at seven on
the new reality
crystal looks at what some employers are
doing to keep workers safe
that's right here on global
and that is global national for this
friday i'm farah nasser thanks for
spending part of your evening with us
we want to leave you tonight with this
touching drawing my mikma artist whitney
gould
a tribute to those 215 indigenous
children in kamloops
she says she was inspired by a quote and
the small
voice whispers they found us
thank you for watching good night